hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the unknown a
randomly generated game of nightmares
and death or at least that's what I'm
assuming it is this was made during the
Asylum jam that have only started to get
games off from I've been trying to find
the good ones and this one supposedly is
one of the better ones I've also checked
out the website there's a dead man
walking Studios has another project
rebirth that there are that's currently
greenlit on Steam and from the looks of
it looks fantastic but this was made in
48 hours and I am ready darlin biscuit
winner oh hey we're finally in the game
alright alright alright well the whole
time is and you can still hear it now oh
it sounds like something is gnawing on
something on the inside of my ear oh
it's kind of like an amnesia you know
when he was starting to go insane and
heard the bugs calling on him oh yeah
look anyway was this creepy lady statue
escaped the trap of Morpheus to once
again be free but Charles Obul is not
enough I require three ah stop bad how
bad okay I just pushed the doors open
with my fists
Oh what does that sound is so
disconcerting only those who gaze into
the unknown shall know true fear was
that supposed to mean am I supposed to
look and uh the unknown or what wish
okay nope what you want
hey I heard something breezing and I
breathing breathing and I saw a red mist
oh ah okay I don't hear any noises
coming from here so let's go this way
Oh me not like you this game man if this
had oculus rift support I would already
be crapping my pants not saying I am now
but if if it was AA kiss rift what the
that's that's upside-down Oh what what
what and these barrels they're floating
in mid-air the flowing in midair and I
hear something breathing well I'm sorry
I didn't mean to touch the door ah Wow
God what are you oh my move-move-move
barrels in zero gravity I got something
after me ah that's what I saw before
yeah it's ah yeah it's floating it's
slightly disturbing it's moderately
creepy in a way
okay um huh I'm gonna I'm gonna go this
way I'm gonna not what is that oh wait a
minute I didn't see this door before
let's go in this door that I didn't see
before
and then I'll die and be no more
you're like bugs I don't know why I hear
bugs but I do Oh gasps oh that's just a
thing oh you shut your mouth oh you shut
before you get the back of my hand be
all the boys bunk ah stop
yeah stop breathing don't get all
breathing heavy what was that
ah there's so many noises this is pretty
impressive for a game that was made in
48 hours and once again oh hi what what
are you oh he's looking at me ah another
one what do I do
ah what up Frick did you come from what
you went bravely how did you [ __ ] I got
a choice word to say nil Boni oh yes I
guess I was a dead end I ah I died from
what that's this can't just alright
whatever you know regenerating level
please wait may take a while your face
takes a while for me to get used to cuz
you're so ugly whoa oh whoa oh that took
much less time than before what did I
die from that's what I would like to
know I'd get back I don't know I don't
know huh only those who gaze into the
unknown shall know truth yeah okay
whatever I don't know what's going on in
this game mister wish I did
okay so stay away from the breathe
the red brief II heavy which I'm
apparently going right whoa I got it's
the red brainy heavy Oh No I sure wish I
knew why I was in this dungeon of
despair I sure what what why is this all
brightly lit uh-oh
Oh No am i doing Oh
as not a good god what oh boy I can't
yeah
some things are getting in my eyes can't
quite see I'm not gonna go in the wooden
plank when there's a bow oh I see oh
wait what no I want no what no what we
know god damn it
but are you kidding me the mouse was
outside the game but I think that's a
factor of me playing it on how do I go
get this one it oh there we go I just
wasn't looking at it right enough okay
so I need Oh what is happening what what
is this ah it was a spiky trap is how it
killed me before ah I don't know what's
going on I know what's going on but both
I mean I have to like it girl yeah I'm
trying to I'm trying to play this I know
some of you were like they're like no
you thought bad a game what you need to
do is XYZ well I'm sorry that you have
oh god it's right there I'm sorry that
you have a perception level of 20 and
you rolled your skills check and got all
twenties across the board
nice st. 20 a lot mmm but I do not have
the perception of an ocelot ever the
eyes of a hawk in the ears of a badger
was something behind me I don't know it
sounded like something was behind me
it sounded like something was literally
right behind me God sometimes I
sometimes I really hate these headphones
that they're so good with the burial or
3d ICU how do I not die how do I not die
ah Wow Wow whoa how do I not die it Oh
Oh late parkour Oh what the hell is this
what is this there's a series of rocks I
don't know what I'm doing so story um
are are goddamn it I don't know what I'm
doing oh it's this room again well is
there actually anything useful in here
this time oh well that's disturbing the
hell it's looking at me oh god damn it
get away from me yes yeah no way from me
oh god damn oh man you're so weird
are you so weird get out my way ah come
on barrel you son of a [ __ ] barrel I'm
gonna I'm gonna Jack slap you want it I
can crouch but I can't crouch jump
well schnikeys yeah I guess I can't go
that way I'm gonna I'm not gonna keep
trying
it's a fruitless venture behind her
there's no miner huh yeah yeah that
weird
chewing fifth
this game is like three parts disgusting
two parts weird for parts freaky and one
part what the [ __ ] is that ten did that
equal ten what is this ah
the walls are oozing red slime oh no
wait that's blood oh my bad
common mistake I still hear that
breathing I'm not going up there
screw that screw all about that I've
died every time I go stairs what is this
I'm peering into the darkness you [ __ ]
yeah what huh
wait what where am I whoa what the hell
Wow
ah tablet yeah I'm going around screw
you
okay Oh where's the gold oh god fine
I'll go upstairs but I guess I gotta die
again
son of a [ __ ] and all your all Oh
two dead end oh look the head it's just
a bit it's it is head-butting me
hey hey you cut that up you are you so
cute ah you little scamp let me just
nudge your hair and be on my way ah
you're adorable
Oh what happens if I walk across the
plain oh nothing I thought it would
break for sure
I never mind then into the darkness I
guess where did I come from where did I
go where did you come from cotton-eye
Joe Fattah paddy for DARPA died oh well
wow that's weird
those more comical than it Oh God not
you again Oh hmm
oh boy
here we go again what other nightmare do
you have in store for me now was this
room what is this room
oh is this a room I died in I guess
don't huh it's just an empty room I
think I was supposed to find gold in
some of these places but I just ended up
not the objective I pretty sure is to
find three of the gold things and then
go back to the lady to briber to get you
out of this hellhole but that's not
working for me because I'm an idiot oh
hi hello
oh ah I died
what I'm heading head-butting me in the
groin really that killed me okay so hi I
was having fun with that actually that
was actually pretty interesting I mean
for my criticisms aside obviously this
was made in 48 hours
you cannot like put that much um burden
on how good it's gonna be it's for 48
hours this is pretty darn well made you
gotta admit I mean a lot of people don't
put this much effort into their game
when it's like supposed to be this
quantico professional will he made indie
game is that a that a counterintuitive
but anyway that was actually really good
I mean I'm not gonna beat it obviously
cuz I can't even get one back to home
base but hey it's not bad if you guys
want to give me a try I'll give it a try
don't give me a try give me everything
no I mean seriously it's not bad it
really is pretty good I mean this speaks
highly of the company that made it
that's working on their other game so I
put a link in the description below of
the web of the website of the maker and
uh check out their other game project
they don't have any playable demos out
but um it's really cool it's supposed to
be another procedurally generated game
with this one in outdoors or the other
one in outdoors so I'll check it out I
think it's dead man walking studios I
have no idea what do you the way thank
you all so much for watching click the
in today's more videos that I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye
oh my god
will
Pournami
very close now